وطبعا مشاهدينا هم اللي خلينا بس نذكر
انهم هم قاموا بمهمتهم هذه يوم الاحد
الماضي وقاموا خلال عشره ايام قاموا ب 14
تجربه علميه او دراسه علميه رائده فيها
كثير من الدراسات عن بنتكلم مجال الدماغ
الجهاز العصبي الخلايا المناعيه وبنتكلم
كمان عن تكنولوجيا استمطار المياه طبعا
ريانه برناوي وعلي القرني اول اثنين يعني
سعوديين بيطلعوا الى
الفضاء وبصلوا لي المحطه الفضاء الدوليه
وهم طبعا بيكونوا كذلك انهم يعني ما يكون
كذا وصل عدد الرواد الفضاء اللي السعوديين
اللي طلعوا لي الفضاء ثلاثه وبكده بيكونوا
اعلى عدد طبعا او في الدول العربيه هذه
مشاهد مباشره الان بنشوفها وحنستمر طبعا
في متابعه الموضوع لانه في اي لحظه
ممكن تبتدي عمليه الانفصال وانفصال
المركبه الفضائيه دراغون عن المحطه او
محطه الفضاء الدوليه
عشر ايام مرت على انطلاق المهمه العلميه
الى الفضاء واللي شاركت فيها السعوديه
ممثله براي الفضاء علي القرني وريانه
برناوي اليوم بدات رحله العوده وغادر علي
وريانه محطه الفضاء الدوليه وصاروا في
مركبه دراغون اللي انفصلت من دقائق عن
محطه الفضاء الدوليه وكان علي وريانه
عملوا خلال مهمتهم على عدد من التجارب
العلميه ونفذوا تجارب في علم الخليه
وكانوا على اتصال عبر الاقمار الصناعيه مع
كثير من الطلاب اللي سالوهم وجاوبوهم على
اسئلتهم وعلي وريانه كانوا طلعوا في فيديو
من محطه الفضاء الدوليه وادعوا في زملائهم
الموجودين في المحطه وريان غلبت هد دموعها
خلال الوداع
الات فروميو انا جود ماي تايم هير هوفر
اند ثانكيو
اجري
اند تيك اوف ديس انك
هنا كانت جدا جدا جميل جدا متعاون انبسطنا
معاهم كلهم مع القسم الروسي مع رائد
الفضاء سلطان النيادي من الامارات مع
جروب اكسيوم صراحه كان
[موسيقى]